a top commander of the pakistani taliban
abdul wali mahmud has been killed in
neighboring afghanistan that's according
to pakistani government officials
was on the u.s state department's wanted
list
osama bin jabed is live in kaaba with
more on this now osama what more can you
tell us
well it is a major blow to the pakistani
taliban also known as tariq taliban
pakistan or ttp
abdullah
also known as um
was a leading figure known for not just
his brutality but his effective use of
uh social media as well uh to put the
group on the map uh in the last two
decades or so he's
we have to realize that he's been uh
reportedly killed at least six times
beforehand three of them being uh drone
strikes which went after him so this is
somebody uh who's been reported dead and
has uh
and that's not come out to be true
multiple times before so waiting for the
group to actually confirm his death they
have told al jazeera that uh there is
going to be a declaration about uh quote
his martyrdom but it is a significant uh
action
against the group
there is still a bit of mystery
shrouding how he was killed as reports
suggest that he was in his car and was
killed with two of the commanders uh
with either a roadside bomb or a rocket
we don't know
why he was moving from paktika in the
eastern part of afghanistan towards
pakistan or was it another location that
he was moving to but in the last few
days we've heard about movements of
various commanders move belonging not
just the ttp but other groups as well uh
trying to relocate themselves especially
after the u.s drone strike which killed
eminent zwahiri a few days ago here in
the afghan capital kabul it does bring
into question the taliban claims that
afghan soil is not going to be used to
harbor or to orchestrate attacks against
anyone else by any other foreign groups
but there are multiple groups which have
been present in this country for the
last two decades it is also interesting
to note that this killing comes
at a point when pakistan was closer to
the group although talks had stalled but
there have been multiple rounds of
dialogues that have been held by various
aspects of the pakistani leadership
including religious leaders as well as
military commanders as they tried to
find a solution
in the wake of a spike of attacks in
pakistan by the tariqa taliban pakistan
a blow to the group and also question
marks to whether those talks are going
to go ahead or are going to
break down with the pakistani government
especially after omar khalid kulasani a
senior member a senior leader of the
pakistani taliban reportedly being
killed in a roadside bombing
osama bin laden live for us in kabul
thank you for that update